so the attack is a terrorist responsible
for ramming for the ramming attack in
Germany has been reportedly identified
as Talib Al ABD a Zionist atheist and an
ex-muslim Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping the reward click
the link and donate what you
Canam brothers and sisters and dear
friends toic
a horrific attack took place in a
Christmas Market in Germany brothers and
sisters and as you guys know the far
right Elon Musk and oddly oddly I want
to say oddly Andrew T jumped at
opportunity I mean if Tommy Robinson was
uh out from prison he would have jumped
out the opportunity he would have be
celebrating and just hoping and making a
Christmas wish to Santa that please let
it be a Muslim sadly not and very
bizarrely Andrew Tate jumped on this I
don't know what's his has he got a chip
on his shoulder what does he need to
prove to who we've got so many evidences
guys so much evidence Subhan Allah that
he was an exm Muslim activist who was on
the BBC for some odd reasons these
people who love to Massacre main people
they have this correlation I'm not
saying correlation causes coration you
know like even the what happened that
horrific attack in Southport those
innocent girls being killed the the
perpetrator again a he was a Christian
this time was on the BBC I don't know
what's going on with BBC and you know uh
they keep um choosing mentally unwell or
should we say not unwell but individuals
who are targeting innocent people so you
can see very clearly brother sisters
this man his name was tala Abdul yes
okay so you can see here the translation
says what he was the supporter of the
same party that Elon Musk is also
supporting ironically the afd party in
my experience the German police are the
real drivers of islamism in Germany so
he's an anti-islam he's an islamophobic
bigot just like the scumbag the dirt bag
the filth of the filth I mean his face
looks wretched yes Aus yes um it's are
you going to be condemning this is the
ex-muslim community going to come out
and condemn these attacks because it
seems like it's becoming a pattern now
yes he says my experience in seven years
of police police uh using dirty tactics
against me and other critics of Islam
most recently in March 2024 the to
destroy our anti-islam activism the uh
the left are crazy we need afd to
protect the police from them
this is an interview well I uh graduated
from Medical School uh in Riyad Saudi
Arabia and then I moved to Germany I
specialized in there you go and not only
that bizar guys guess who was a fan of
this man no other than your uh local
islamophobe Tommy Robinson yes Tommy
Robinson actually followed him okay
actually followed him and I think they
followed each other yes uh and let me
guess he's a double agent no oh yeah I'm
sure he is not only that he was a proud
Zionist he was a proud Zionist in this
PO he says what I was the first Israeli
to support the Syrian Revolution and
today 80% of the Israeli people are with
me there we go guys and not only that we
have more we have more to come what do
we know about the attaka so the Atta is
a terrorist responsible for raming for
the ramming attack in Germany has been
reportedly identified as Talib Al abdin
a Zionist atheist and an ex-muslim we're
waiting for the ex-muslim community to
condemn his attacks Saudi born
psychiatrist and activist he lived in
Germany since 2006 he's extremely
anti-islam he proudly expressed his
Tendencies to slaughter Germans on X
very weirdly he is wanted by the Saudi
Arabia on charges related terrorism
smuggling guils from Saudi Arabia which
are ex-muslims by the way and the Gulf
States to EU countries Germany has
refused to extradite him to Saudi Arabia
and granted him political Asylum despite
charges being brought against him and
very bizarrely the newspapers this was
one of them says uh they're trying to
make a correlation before they found out
who he even really was so this is um
Coban Robins yes it was early evening
when a car plowed into a people at a
Christmas Market in meberg the timing of
the incident which is being called an
attack was especially cruel on the final
Friday before Christmas families will
have been there with their children
soaking up the festive atmosphere you
see how the the the the the the the
wording the child is believe a child is
believed to be among the dead according
to the state Premier you see when it's a
non-muslim it's a child when when it's
the Palestinians it is a boy or a young
man who was killed and we condemn any
kind of innocence in in the video
footage the market appeared busy with
many people fishing finishing work today
for holidays Christmas markets are a
populous place to go now what dides she
say after same lady says what check it
out she tries to make some kind of a
correlation this attack happened 8 years
after a failed Tunisian Asylum Seeker
with islamist links crashed a truck into
Crow at Christmas Market in Berlin 30
people died they need to make that
correlation so this was an interview
let's watch a quick interview of this
man on um BBC let's see inshah one
second uh hi my name is Talib I'm from
Saudi Arabia I'm an activist I created a
website to help people seeking Asylum
especially from Saudi Arabia and the the
Gul region
[Music]
yeah I use I use basically WhatsApp
Twitter U telegram if I have time uh I
spend uh you know totally helping Saudi
sound seers between 10 to 16 hours a day
if I have
time the only Arab country from which I
did not have an ex-muslim seeking help
until now from me is Oman
uh 90% of people who approach me are
women between 18 and 13 years
old Islam is biggest yes uh absolute
morons intellectual scums dirt bags yes
because this scumbag apus yes P animous
devil absolutely evil yes it's like have
to agree with you here every winter I
think of those wonderful Christmas
markets in Germany just you know this
this propaganda is beautiful I think of
those wonderful Christmas markets in
Germany I'm sure you what you do here is
yet another islamist seeking to destroy
something so beautiful many have been
killed and injured when the hell with
the West wake up when the hell would the
W West wake up and get rid of this
problem now funnily enough bizarrely
enough my friend he was an
ex-muslim he's from your Camp he agrees
with you 100% he agrees with this he
disagrees with Islam
100% how does this feel and Andrew Tate
shame on you I don't know what kind of
chip you got on your shoulder mate I
don't know what you're trying to prove
to who yes you and Tommy Robinson well
if he was out here would have been
jumping on this as well you should be
embarrassed of yourself look at you
jumping at the opportunity of when is
we're going to deal with the islamist
problem yes okay now do we have extreme
individuals in our religion of course
like anyone else does any other religion
or political party whatever you want to
name it everyone has that the fact that
you're jumping on this without even
verifying shows the utter embarrassment
on your behalf when are you going to
stop this you done same thing with
Southport what agenda do you have what
agenda do you have there's trying to be
big question marks on your head not
about your Islam if you're a Muslim we
don't doubt that okay we need certainty
to take you out the F of Islam and we
don't have that not that we want it but
the thing is I don't understand the chip
on your shoulder why are you so adamant
why are you so eager why are you so
eager to make this an islamist thing are
you normally in the head you're a Muslim
yourself what's your issue okay we all
have these problems in different
religions and this was a what an
ex-muslim activist an atheist a Zionist
why do you blame it and even there was
AOS of him saying the True Religion the
true God is the god of Israel or
something like that for that matter so
why are you not talking about that why
are you not mentioning this that's all I
have to say guys we're going to be
keeping up to date with this kind of
stuff and more videos will be coming
inallah but as you can see guys share
this far and wide to let the world whole
world see that if this was a Muslim you
know exactly what would happen now that
he's a Zionist atheist ex-muslim we want
this communities to condemn this attack
and do something about it because it's
starting to become a common problem
that's all I have to say brother and
sisters inshallah I will keep you more
updated with these videos inshallah and
one thing that I want to mention nowhere
in Islam or in our religion does it tell
us that we should um be against the
Christmas celebration look people can
celebrate Christmas that's their
religion there's nothing in Islam that
says that we have to stop them that's
their faith that's their religion to
your religion to us ours thank you very
much we love Jesus we don't celebrate
that so it's my faith it's like for
example if I was to go for example if if
we was to say um for example peace be
upon him yes the Muhammad peace be upon
him I can't go and force somebody to say
that if they don't believe if they say I
do not believe the prophet Muhammad to
be a prophet I mean I wouldn't expect
him to insult the prophet wasam however
I would not go and say to him that you
have to say peace be upon him after his
name he might say I don't have I don't
want to that's up to you I cannot it's
the same with say Merry Christmas I
don't need to say that because I believe
it's a great blasphemy against God
Almighty so that's the other thing that
we have no problem with you celebrating
Christmas there's nothing in our
religion that says we should attack
anyone for their religious festivities
or whatever it's for that matter that
even though it's going enough to do with
Christianity but that's all I have to
say brother sisters till next
time the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tal tells us that our books will be
given and every little atom weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masid oh Allah
you helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]